transportée sur ce brancard un ukrainien
grièvement blessé il est l'une des
nombreuses victimes du bombardement
russe qui a touché quelques heures plus
tôt selon viance
un dernier baiser de son épouse à
l'hopital du kram à tort sq et le voilà
parti en direction d'un autre
établissement de la région
rous la nuit n'a pas été blessé mais il
a perdu son magasin partis en fumée il
ne peut s'empêcher de verser une larme
d'un génocide pour que les gens aient
peur l'essentiel
moscou a aussi frappé nicolas yves ce
quartier résidentiel n'est plus qu'un
immense amas de cendres
après s'être emparé de la province de
l'eau ans que ce week end la russie de
vladimir poutine a jeté son dévolu sur
celle voisine de donetsk
l'autre moitié du dombass qui n'est pas
encore sous son contrôle les villes de
ce l'audience nicolas yves et barmou
peuvent trembler
alors que son pays a déjà cédé 20 % de
son territoire à l'envahisseur russe
volodymyr zelensky a taclé son état
major en cause l'application d'une règle
interdisant aux conscrits de quitter
leur région et leur lieu de résidence et
ce sans l'aval des autorités militaires
hérité de l'union soviétique
elle va bientôt être modifié car dans
cette guerre aucun soldat ne sera de
troupes pour l'ukraine